Prince Harry and Megan Marco the parents
to me are making news again tonight as
the Royals boarded their Qantas flight
from Tonga to Sydney
they couldn't have expected this you can
see Megan and Harry's jet just a few
feet from landing before abruptly
pulling up and taking to the skies again
the pilot had to suddenly abort the
landing because there was another plane
on the runway the jet took off again and
circled around the city before finally
touching down safely
[Music]
despite the in air drama the two seem to
be unshaken after their flight as they
immediately got to work again
Megan donned an amazing tool and tweed
laser-cut cocktail dress by Oscar de la
Renta as she and Harry presented awards
at the Australian Geographic Society I
am delighted to be able to announce that
the Australian Geographic young
conservationist of the Year for 2018 is
Sofia scartaris earlier in the day
before their flight the two shared a
lighthearted goal
they watch the men's choir perform
during the spirited singing megan seemed
to burst into a fit of giggles back
stateside pregnant Amy Schumer is
showing her love for the Royals she
photoshopped her and her husband Chris
Fischer's heads atop Megan and Harry's
bodies as another way to let the world
know she's expecting Amy was also
snapped on the streets of New York
caressing her little tummy bump just
like we've seen Megan do every day on
her tour
[Music]